Das ist wirklich nicht gut!
Das Grundwasser geht zur Neige!
Das sagt eine neue Studie.
Demnach sinken durch lange Dürreperioden,
wie hier in Europa im letzten Sommer, die
Grundwasserspiegel unwiederbringlich!
Die nächste absolute Katastrophe.
Und die Politik?.... versagt!
Die selbst gesteckten Klimaziele werden in
Deutschland verfehlt!
Danke liebe Politik!
Ihr habt versagt!
Und aber danke an alle jungen Menschen, die
freitags auf die Straße gehen und sich das
nicht gefallen lassen!
Clixoom Science & Fiction.
Wir unterstützen jede Aktion gegen den Klimawandel!
Macht mit!
Eure Kinder werden euch fragen, was ihr dagegen
getan habt!
Herzlich willkommen!
Wir haben es geschafft!
Damals, als ich zur Schule gegangen bin, haben
wir gestreikt.
Vier Wochen lang.
Die ganze Schule.
Und?
Wir haben es geschafft!
Damals ging es um die langsame Vergiftung
der ganzen Schule und unsere Direktorin ließ
es zu.
Konkret: In der ganze Schukle waren Formaldehyd-haltige
Deckenplatten verbaut worden.
Die Folgen: Nasenbluten, Kopfschmerzen und
mögliche Langzeitschäden wie zum Beispiel
Krebs.
Ich selber hatte immer Kopfschmerzen und ein
sehr seltsames trockenes Nasenbluten.
Im Büro der Direktorin waren die Deckenplatten
allerdings ausgebaut worden.
Ein Schelm, wer Böses dabei denkt;) Hmm.
Aber für uns Schüler war es einfach nicht
gut in dieser Schule zu sein.
Also haben wir gehandelt und gestreikt.
Vier Wochen lang und danach hat der damalige
Kölner Oberstadtdirektor endlich gehandelt
und die Platten ausbauen lassen.
Wir hatten gewonnen!
Und ehrlich gesagt habe ich dabei mehr gelernt,
als während des Unterrichts!
Und es ist wieder Zeit dafür!
Unsere Gesellschaft lebt auf Kosten der jungen
Generation und das wirklich haltlos.
Es ist beschämend.
Die neueste Hiobsbotschaft: Der Grundwasserspiegel
sinkt …. unaufhaltsam!
Eine Studie einer internationalen Forschungsgruppe
kommt zu einem ernüchternden Eregbnis: werden
sich weltweit die Hälfte der Grundwasserreservoirs
nicht mehr auffüllen.
Es wird einfach mehr Wasser verbraucht, als
nachfließt.
Im Iran hat sich das letztes Jahr durch dramatischen
Wassermangel gezeigt, der schließlich lokal
zu Volksaufständen geführt hatte.
Im Iran sind 97 Prozent des Landes von anhaltender
Trockenheit betroffen.
In mehreren Städten dort gibt es einfach
kein Trinkwasser mehr.
Die Bevölkerung protestierte dagegen.
Es sollen bei Auseinandersetzungen mit der
Polizei Demonstranten erschossen worden sein.
Angeblich ist ein Rohrbruch schuld, doch der
Iran leidet unter einem Fehler im System,
hervorgerufen durch den Klimawandel.
Die Temperaturen stiegen hier bereits doppelt
so stark im Durchschnitt auf der Erde um bis
zu 2 Grad.
Der Wasserverbrauch ist dabei immens.
Die Vereinten Nationen empfehlen 20 Prozent
der Wassermenge zu verbrauchen, die durch
Regen wieder aufgefüllt wird.
Im Iran sind es 110 Prozent.
Dem Land geht einfach das Wasser aus.
Es wird wohl nicht mehr vermeidbar sein, dass
12 von 31 Provinzen in naher Zukunft unbewohnbar
werden.
Die Folgen: Durst, Hunger, Revolten und damit
die Instabilität der ganzen Region.
Flucht nach Europa.
Und selbst Regen und selbst hier in Europa
hilft da oft nicht mehr, wenn er in Sturzfluten
auf uns niederprasselt.
Das Wasser landet dann nicht mehr in den Grundwasserreservoiren,
sondern fließt einfach ab. 2016 war der trockenste
Sommer seit 1963 und 2018 der heißeste Sommer
seit Beginn der Wetteraufzeichnungen 1881
in deutschland.
Auch wir werden von diesen Entwicklungen nicht
verschont.
Das Forschungsteam wertete jetzt Grundwasserdaten
aus und stießen auf eine Zeitbombe.
In den kommenden hundert Jahren werden die
Hälfte aller Grundwasservorkommen nicht mehr
aufgefüllt.
Wir müssen etwas tun.
Und deshalb erstmal Respekt an jede und jeden,
der freitags streikt und auf die Straße geht!
Jeder sollte alles tun, was in seiner Macht
steht, um etwas zu verändern.
Deshalb macht weiter und ich werde weiter
euch von hier aus unterstützen.
Ein riesen problem ist ja auch das weltweite
Plastikproblem.
Helft mir bitte dabei, dagegen etwas zu tun
und folgt und verbreitet dem Instagram-Account
“GetridofPlastics” Werdet Plastik lois
auf deutsch Dafür hier unbedingt und bitte
drauflicken!
Ansonsten: Bis dann, bleibt dran!